the man who kicks us off every single
day here on nbc sports on peacock
and wraps it up with pro football talk
live as well as pft pm mike florio here
on the richard shaw are you mike
rich i'm doing great here's how crazy
the weekend was we spent two hours
talking about week 12
earlier today chris sims and i yeah and
we did not mention at any point in 120
minutes the firing
of lions coach matt patricia and gm bob
quinn or the firing of jaguars gm dave
caldwell
mention it perfect news dump the
ultimate weekend
to fire a coach or a gm and it goes
completely unnoticed because there's so
much else going on there's so much else
going on let's start with the denver
broncos
situation and i'd love for you to clear
up what many people
have uh i think conflated and confused
as to
you know why why would the nfl not push
the game because
so many quarterbacks go down uh i know
you know what uh the protocols are and
what the rules that were agreed to
before the season and what the latest
might be
so lay it all out for me right here mike
go for it well rich there was a time
before the season where it was believed
that in certain circumstances if a team
for example has no
healthy offensive lineman they're all on
the coveted list or otherwise injured
or no quarterbacks or some other
competitive reason for postponing a game
that's when the commissioner would
convene this
external advisory panel that was put
together as an alternative to the
competition committee because there
would be
conflicts of interest galore if you have
current competition committee members
making these decisions
that that would be fair game that games
potentially would be postponed
simply because hey we've got no healthy
offensive lineman
in october the league decided and this
was an ownership move that that's not
how it's going to work
competitive issues will not drive these
decisions if you don't have guys ready
to play
that's on you there's enough roster
flexibility this year
53 guys on the active roster 16 on the
practice squad
you should have enough players to play
and at some level it's your
responsibility to ensure
that your players stay on the right side
of the virus so
for the broncos when jeff driscoll
test positive when the broncos and
actually this falls into the no
good deed goes unpunished file the
broncos found surveillance footage from
their quarterback meeting room
they saw that there was a moment or
maybe longer but not for the entire
meeting when guys didn't have their
masks up they
sent it to the league and when they
heard back from the league the league
said they're all knocked out
for tomorrow's game and the broncos had
basically 24 hours
to figure out what they were going to do
but that's how it works and the broncos
lobbied
aggressively to get the game delayed a
day or two so they could get
their quarterbacks back who had not
tested positive
we're just on this covet 19 reserve list
the league said no we're not going to do
it
the game is going forward the contrast
is the raven situation
an uncontained outbreak where the league
still didn't know how deep the rabbit
hole went whether the transmissions were
still happening they weren't going to
let the ravens back into the facility
they weren't going to put them on the
field
until they know that it's over and they
still haven't concluded that it's over
tuesday night's game could still get
moved but that's the difference
competitive reasons
we'll never postpone a game reasons
related to an uncontained outbreak
that's when the nfl at this point will
say we're going to slide a game back
a day or two or longer so what is the
status right now
of uh twofold the quarterbacks room in
denver
and then that tuesday night game uh and
thus the
uh pushed uh monday night game uh
thursday night game to monday for the
ravens what's the current status of both
of those situations
well in denver it's just a matter of the
procedures unfolding that would get the
guys back who didn't test
positive there's the two levels of covet
19 reserve list you test positive
you're knocked out for at least a week
week and a half you get put on it
because you had close contact with
someone who's positive you can come back
in as short as five days and they should
get their guys back
barring a positive test by any of them
whether it's
drew locke or brett ripon or blake
bortles those guys should be back
my understanding was today possibly
tomorrow either way
in time for next week's game sunday
night against the
kansas city chiefs as it relates to the
ravens look we went from thursday
we went to sunday now we're at tuesday
they were
assembled in the facility properly
spaced
at 9 25 a.m eastern this morning waiting
for word from the nfl as to whether or
not they could have a 9 30 a.m walk
through
the league said no can't do it postponed
and i saw albert breer reported until
5 pm 5 p.m is specifically relevant rich
because by then
the ravens will have their daily pcr
off-site testing
results back it depends on how close you
are to a laboratory
the ravens are close to a laboratory
they get theirs late afternoon early
evening
so i think the nfl wants to see are
there more positives today
and i think and and who knows i don't
want to make bad assumptions but i
assume
if there's more positives today no walk
through i don't know what that means
about the game tomorrow night
but everything is still tenuous it's
still hanging in the balance
yes they were back in the facility last
night on a voluntary basis for
conditioning
but no practice yet no green light yet
to practice
and even though the game is still
technically on i i sense that there's
still a chance the game
based upon results of these tests today
and tomorrow
the game could still end up being off
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
pro football talk pro football talk
live pro football pft pm uh all of it
here on
on nbc sports on peacock what's the plan
um if this game does get pushed or any
obviously you're seeing it's getting
worse in the country
i mean december is going to be a white
knuckler december starts as we know
tuesday
so what's the plan for the nfl for a
possible week 18 i'm hearing about
bubbles for the playoffs what are you
hearing about all that right now
mike i wish they would just get into a
bubble right now and i really do think
it's a matter of collective bargaining
where you've got labor and management
staring each other down
management doesn't want to ask because
then the union will say what's in it for
us you have to make a concession you're
asking our players to abandon their
families for the rest of the season and
live in a hotel
that's a significant change to working
conditions we need something in return
the league doesn't want to give them
something in return that's how
collective bargaining goes
and the union doesn't want to blink on
their own and just say well
the hell with it we're risking losing
game checks if games are lost
and never played let's volunteer to go
into a hotel and
i i feel like they're just waiting for
that one moment where the walls cave in
and both sides say screw it we're going
to put everybody in a hotel for the rest
of the season i'd like to think they'd
come to an agreement
before the walls came in but this may be
one where the walls need to cave in rich
and
week 18 is something the nfl has been
resisting and resisting and it
it it kind of hit me today why they're
resisting
if you would move raven steelers to week
18 right now
well there goes the buffer for the
ravens and the steelers what if bill
steelers can't be played
next sunday night does that game just
disappear because
obviously the steelers can't play two
games week 18 how do you decide which
game takes precedence do you play bill
steelers week 18
and scrap raven steelers how do you do
that rock paper scissors
analysis based upon the total number of
games that would get moved to week 18.
i've heard from a couple of different
people there's maybe an idea that if
they would ever pull
that that rip cord on week 18 it
wouldn't just be
for a game or two it would be throw in
the towel on a full week
and move that week to week 18. now i
don't know that they want to do that
either
but there are some serious ripple
effects of moving one game to week 18
because
for the two teams involved for every
game they play the rest of the way
there is no wiggle room and then you may
end up
having to decide between games that
that will get played won't get played
who gets prioritized who finishes with
15 who gets 16.
and it just becomes a huge mess for the
nfl i think that's one of the big
reasons why
they've resisted kicking any games to a
week 18. yeah i know that's why that
they're going to try and
you know tell the ravens hold up um you
know hold up until at least
dinnertime before you can walk through
and then get on a plane tomorrow even
though apparently it's supposed to snow
in pittsburgh on tuesday in the morning
i mean there might actually be travel
issues now
on top of all of it and then there's the
issue of the 49ers
even if they bubble up they might not be
able to bubble up in in their hometown
they they might be you know on the road
essentially
for the first few weeks of
of december right up until christmas
time what's the status
of all that right now mike well i was
told yesterday that
the 49ers wanted to today talk to the
officials in santa clara county and see
if there's any way to stick handle their
way
around this rule that essentially
prevents them from playing
at their home stadium can they get an
exception is there an exemption a
dispensation anything if that
doesn't work arizona looks like the
place when the schedule came out in may
one of the first things i noticed
because i knew that the california teams
could have an issue i started crawford
cross-referencing schedules it's like
hey arizona is no problem there would
never be a conflict with the cardinals
never a game that's due to be played on
the same day between the 49ers and
cardinals at home so i think arizona is
the winner
but you know this issue with telling
guys on a team
part of a unionized workforce you got to
go live in a hotel
for the rest of the season that's not
something that the nfl just
automatically gets to do the union is
going to have a say in that
and and and that's an issue that's going
to have to be worked out pretty quickly
because the 49ers have a home game air
quotes home game
next monday night against the buffalo
bills mike florio here on the rich eisen
show okay uh i know you're a big pop
culture guy
and this is a big pop culture place so
let's uh you'll follow me here
uh if um losing your first 11 games
is basically the football god's version
of ordering a code red
and um and adam gases santiago
um why is santiago despite the code red
being ordered not
touched when you see what detroit's done
you've seen what atlanta's done you've
seen what houston's done
what is going on in that situation
well i look there are wild cards and
we've talked about this before and the
biggest wild card i think is owner woody
johnson he's going to be back
at some point we don't know when colonel
jessup is going to be taking the witness
stand
but he will be back and i think
everything is kind of on hold
for now but one of the realities i think
at play here and we've heard people say
well with the pandemic
coaching searches are going to be
complicated i think that's one of the
reasons why teams are getting an early
start
uh if you know it's going to be
complicated because of the pandemic then
then get rolling now
start doing your work now do all your
background work now and be ready to go
when january rolls around so i i just
don't know
what's going on with the jets i don't
know if they're holding out hope that
somehow they win a few games and it
justifies bringing everyone back
i don't know how joe douglas fits into
all of this everyone assumes he'd be
back
if gase is gone but the reality is
douglas was
sort of hand-picked by gase once mike
mccagnan was run out of town and douglas
is on the record saying
gates isn't the problem so i don't think
they know what
they want to do and the fact that they
don't have
fans present to show up wearing the bags
and we talked about this last time i
think you know that
that gives them the ability to to play
out the string
i assume when the string is played out
it's going to end
but i with all these teams now embarking
early on their searches for a new coach
every day that goes by makes it as a
practical matter harder and harder for
the jets so i i don't know
i really don't know what's going on i'm
not sure the jets know what's going on
and we just have to sit back and and see
how it all unfolds so then why did the
uh why why did the lions make their
moves over the weekend
do you think well the last two games
were unacceptable that's what owner
schuler
fordham said they were embarrassed and
shut out for the first time in the
matthew stafford era by the panthers
and an xfl quarterback and then the nfl
houston quarterback it was the xfl
houston quarterback one week the nfl
houston quarterback
ripped them apart the next week and and
that was that and uh saturday afternoon
out of the blue although everyone was
kind of expecting it
both patricia and quinn out and people
were surprised by quinn but look
quinn was the guy who showed up fully
intent on hiring patricia
but waiting until there was an opening
to fire jim caldwell instead of firing
him right out of the gates the problem
is caldwell made the playoffs
one year the next year he was above 500
that raises the bar
for patricia and they never were able to
win
enough games to get past that that ghost
of jim caldwell and i think that that
brought everyone down and now
yet again they hit the reset button in
detroit and
we'll see if they can find somebody who
can come in and finally turn this thing
around
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
so
uh what are you hearing about again
tonight's game uh doug peterson uh
was like it's once it's whence if i go
to herz that indicates that the season's
over
um then the middle of last week there
was a little bit of wiggle room
suddenly created when he introduced some
conditional phrasing
when asked if wence was his quarterback
and he said i would think so
um and now hertz we're here and took
some snaps with the ones over the
weekend are we gonna see jalen hurts
significantly tonight do you think i
think peterson's starting to get some
heat from above
i was surprised by the report from jeff
mclean of the philadelphia inquirer over
the weekend
that last sunday jeffrey lurie the owner
of the team skipped the game in
cleveland
out of frustration with the team and i
want to say to
everyone connected to the organization
and all the fans in philly you still
have a super bowl trophy that wasn't
minted all that long ago but i just feel
like for a lot of those folks
getting a taste of a championship
created a sense where they want to be in
contention far more often
and they're sticking with carson wentz
or at least they have stuck with carson
once because they are stuck with carson
wentz at least through 2021 he's got 25
million
eid for next year no one's going to
touch that and trade not even a brock
osweiler trade is going to get that deal
done where
they give somebody draft picks to get
wentz off their hands
25 million on a cap that's likely going
to be 175
and they just got to make it work and my
guess is everybody's on the hot seat
next year
get through this year as best you can
try to make a late push
last year they were five and seven
before they woke up won their last four
games and won the division
i don't know maybe that happens this
year but the difference was carson wentz
had it last year
he doesn't have it this year it'll be
interesting to see if they see
jalen hurts on the field tonight and how
much whether it makes a difference
whether that wakes up carson wentz i
still feel like
he is trying in one fell swoop to
justify
everything that they've done that shows
faith in him from trading up to draft
him
to picking him over nick foles to giving
him the big contract
i feel like he thinks with one play with
one decision with one moment
he can make it all right and i just
think he's trying too hard
to make the eagles look good for riding
with
them as long as they have and it just
feels like next year it's going to be
make or break for carson weinstein
i mean you're more attuned to the
dollars and cents than i am mike you
know
i'm more of a narrative big picture guy
when i do my job
um so i'll ask you this dee
is there any comparison where uh
you know in this era of this new era if
you will
where uh best player out of college is
becomes the highest paid player in the
history of the franchise ever since they
changed that
that uh that that we saw somebody
drafted high
gets paid they do win the super bowl in
the window
in which he was on his first contract
but he wasn't the one who won it
does get paid and then within a year
regresses to the point where you're
wondering
if he's even viable i this is new right
since since they changed the draft rules
in terms of the contracts and who gets
paid
what that this is a completely this is
like a unicorn
right yeah absolutely i mean usually
with a franchise quarterback you know
early that he's going to be a franchise
quarterback and once he reaches that
level
he's always there you have it or you
don't
and you don't have it and then lose it
and that's what's so weird
it's the steve blass all of a sudden
losing his control
that's that takes us way back about
baseball
but that doesn't happen to quarterbacks
that's why it's always such
a safe investment relatively speaking in
comparison to other positions you know
you pay a running back you don't know
what's going to happen pay a receiver
you don't know what's going to pay a
defensive line you don't know what's
going on
pay a quarterback he's just going to
keep doing what he's done no big deal
that's what makes it so stunning and
that's why i still think that
one of these days when you consider how
cheap it is to go out
and reload the cannon with a first round
quarterback one of these teams is going
to say
to a guy who objectively is good enough
is going to say sorry we're just not
doing it sorry and we're not going to do
the franchise tag dance like washington
did
with kirk cousins they did that two
years before they let him walk just from
the moment the contract expires
we're not in this or go hit the market
go see what else is out there
and then after you see what else is out
there if you want to talk maybe we'll
talk
but but i i expect that to happen at
some point i thought it was going to
happen with jared goff
frankly i thought that's the direction
the rams were moving in and based on
yesterday's game
you could say maybe they should have
moved in that direction but between goff
and wentz back to back top of the 2016
draft i
they both got paid and i think there's
reason to wonder whether
those contracts should have been given
out to both guys even though goff right
now
clearly performing significantly better
oh yeah mike appreciate the time
enjoyed tonight's game let's uh let's
chat before the holidays appreciate the
call as always
all right rich take care bye it's mike
florio check him out on pftpm
after brother from another we take this
uh network nbc sports on peacock two
brother from another it's three eastern
time and then
pft pm with mike at five eastern he
starts it all off before dan patrick who
hands it off to us every single day on
nbc sports
on peacock hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here